Et l'ancienne première ministre
du Québec Pauline Marois est
avec nous. Bonsoir Madame Marois
- Bonsoir Madame Galipeau.
- Alors René Lévesque, en quoi
était-il si différent des autres
hommes politiques, parce qu'il a
tellement marqué les Québécois.
- C'était un homme hors nature,
c'est une grandeur hors nature.
C'était un homme d'abord d'une
grande intégrité. Une grande
intégrité, très respectueux
de son peuple. Il aimait
passionnément le Québec
et il aimait passionnément
les citoyennes et les citoyens
du Québec. Et il se préoccupait
du bien commun. C'était
sa raison, la raison de son
engagement en politique.
Et en ce sens-là oui, il était
différent des personnes
politiques souvent que l'on
rencontre, où parfois on se
demande si elle ne travaille pas
un peu plus pour elle-même que
pour les causes qu'elles ont
endossées, alors que René
Lévesque c'était très profond
chez lui que cet engagement.
- Oui, c'est presque
un attachement émotif
des Québécois avec cet homme.
- Oui, parce que les Québécois
sentaient qu'il les aimait.
Les Québécois sentaient qu'il
travaillait pour les aider, pour
les accompagner. Moi j'ai vécu
pleins d'expériences avec lui,
où il nous demandait d'être à
l'écoute de nos concitoyens pour
que nos politiques correspondent
et répondre à leurs besoins.
Et ça, et puis en plus
évidemment, c'était un grand
démocrate, alors il ne voulait
pas qu'on bouscule les
Québécois. Ça aussi c'était
important. Quand on arrivait
avec des projets politiques
qui étaient assez audacieux
il voulait...
- Et il y en avait beaucoup
quand même.
- Il y en avait beaucoup, puis
il y en a eu beaucoup usus son
gouvernement. Mais il voulait
qu'on aille à la rencontre.
Qu'on puisse les consulter,
les entendre. Mais aussi qu'on
soit capable de prendre
des décisions. Et sa grande...
je dirais son grand lègue à cet
égard, c'est d'avoir rendu
les Québécois fiers, fiers
et confiants en eux-êêmes.
D'aller au bout, d'être capable
d'aller au bout de leurs
possibilités, "nous sommes
capables". Et à travers toutes
les grandepopolitiques qu'il a
mise de l'avant, que ce soit
la protection de la langue,
la protection du territoire,
l'assurance auto, qui sont
s s pièces maîtresses,
qui sont toujours d'actualité,
qui ont toujours leur impact.
Essentiellement donc, c'était
de servir les Québécoises
et les Québécois.
- Il y avait cette authenticité
quand il dit : "Vous êtes
quelque chose comme un grand
peuple," on sent que c'est
ce qu'il pensait.
- Absolument. Et quand il arrive
au pouvoir il dit, le soir
du 16 novembre, il dit :
"On ne sera peut-être pas
parfait, peut-être qu'on va
se tromper, peut-être qu'on va
faire des erreurs, mais sachez
que ce sera toujours de bonne
foi et parce qu'on aura voulu
faire au mieux, prendre
les meilleures décisions."
- Donc vous dites il laisse en
héritage cette intégrité, cet
amour des Québécois. Mais il y a
tellement de grands projets de
loi qui ont marqué le Québec.
On pense à la loi sur la
protection des territoires
agricoles, le financement des
partis politiques, la loi 101.
- Absolument. La loi 101 suraa
langue. Et aussi au début de son
mandat, non seulement il y a
la loi sur le financement
des partis politique m mais
il va modifier toute la façon
d'octroyer des contrats.
Il va donc introduire beaucoup
d'exigences  n niveau de cet
aspect qui est absolument
important de la gestion de
l'État, de telle sorte qu'il
n'y t t pas toute forme de
patronage, si on veut. Alors ça
ça l'avait beaucoup heurté quand
il était au Parti libéral, où on
donnait les contrats selon qui
on connaît, etc.
Alors il avait introduit
des lois, des rèemements
pour que on soit très juste
et équitable à cet égard-là.
- Alors parmtotous ces grands
projets de loi, s'il y en avait
un que vous deviez choisir, ou
bien..ququ'est-ce qui serait son
plus grand héritage selon vous?
(rires)
AÀ mon point de vue, le plus
grand lègue, c'est de nous avoir
redonné confiance en nous.
De nous avoir dit : vo  êtes
capable, on n'est pas né
pour un petit pain, c'est faux.
Évidemment après ça, bien c'est
la loi 101, c't t la langue qui
a permis que nous continuions de
vivre en français aujourd'hui.
Ce qui était très périlleux
à l'époe e où il est arrivé
au pouvoir.
- Oui et qui est toujours
tellement d'actualité.
TeTellement. Mais il reste que
son plus grand lègue à mon point
de vue c'est celui-là; c'est
de nous avoir dit : vous êtes
capable, vous avez du talent
et retrouver la fierté de
ce que nous sommes.
- Vous avez des ministres dans
son... dans le deuxième mandat,
du deuxième gouvernement
Lévesque et vous étiez proche
de lui... comment vous vous
souvenez de lui?
- Oh la la, je me souviens
de lui comme d'un homme droit,
un homme qui était assez timide
quand il se retrouvait avec
quelques personnes seulement.
Il était plus capable, il était
davantage capable de nous
transmettre un message quand on
se retrouvait autour de la table
du conseil des ministres
que lorsqu'on se retrouvait
en petits groupes. C'est comme
s'il y avait une certaine pudeur
finalement. Mais sinon, il était
et il restait cet homme simple
et il n'avait pas de double
langage avec lui, ça aussi
c'était rassurant. Quand
il tenait des propos, il aurtt
pu les tenir dehors comme
à l'intérieur et il aurait pu
redire la même chose qui nous
disait devant une foule
finalement. Parce que encore
une fois, c'était son intégrité,
sa sincérité. Et à cet égard
c'est ce dont je me souviens
le plus de lui.
- Il n'était pas parfait.
- Non.
- Et... mais les Québécois
ne semblent pas lui en avoir
tenu rigueur. Parce que bon,
on se souvient des images
à l'époque; il buvait, il fumait
il aimait beaucoup les femmes,
disons-le comme ça. Et pourtant.
(rires)
- Oui c'est vrai. Parce que
encore une fois, il n'a jamais
trompé les Québécois.
Il a respecté la parole donnée
et ce n'était pas seulement
un respect de surface. C'était
un respect profond. Parce qu'il
avait à coeur notre bien-être
finalement. Et ça, ça se sent.
Il aimait les gens. Comme je le
dis souvent; il avait le coeur
à la bonne place. Et ça,
ça ne s'oublie jamais.
- Alors c'est dur de passer
à côté de cette campagne
électorale qui s'amorce, Lucien
Bouchard évidemment a eu ces
propos, qui ont fait beaucoup
réagir, que le PQ n'était peut-
être plus le bon véhicule
pour la souveraineté.
Vous, vous y croyez toujours?
- Je vais voter pour le Parti
québécois.
(rires)
J'y crois toujours.
- Le contraire nous aurait
étonnés quand même.
- Ce qui est assez fascinant,
c'est que pour un parti qu'on
diunun peu moribond, c'est vrai
qu'il vit un peu des
difficultés, on ne va pas le
nier, il a été capable de réunir
actuellement des dizaines
de candidates et de candidss
qui sont des jeunes candidates,
des jeunes candidats. Quand un
parti est sur son déclin, est-ce
que la jeunesse se rallie,
est-ce que la jeunesse a le goût
de venir l'appuyer? Moi je
trouve que c'est de l'espoir que
de voir arriver ces personnes
qui s'engagent au niveau du
Parti québécois. Alors ce part
qui a donné beaucoup au Québec,
nous en avons parlé avec René
Lévesque, a encore beaucoup
à donner et beaucoup à proposer
et il porte un projet, qui est
celui de la liberté d'un peuple,
qui est celui de l'indépendance,
de la souveraineté.
Et à laquelle... auquel je crois
toujours.
- Vous allez participer à cette
campagne personnellement?
- J'ai n'interviendrai
pas quotidiennement dans
la campagne, mais il y aaa
des moments où je serai invité
à prendre la parole et entre
autres dans des grdsds
rassemblements, où je viendrai
appuyer ma formation politique,
avec beaucoudede conviction.
- Encore.
- Oui.
- Merci beaucoup Madame Marois.
- Merc